moving on for martial arts stunt man
what does that involve how do you train
for that what you do on the job freaking
stunts is bonkers man being a stunt man
is a tough gig
all right so for me it was a like actor
performer and martial artist so those
two things
just naturally evolve into yeah yeah
wrestling eventually right
but dude stance is hard firstly you got
to decide
you know are you just going to do stuff
like what i did was you know punching
and kicking and falling down basically
right that was fight scenes
but then stunts also includes cars you
know
boats set on fire yeah yeah like
people's some stuntmen have to like flip
the cars over yeah which is
like that's a whole new skill set right
yeah so it really like
you know it's saying what about stunts
it's kind of like saying how long is a
piece of string there's so many
different things you can do you can't be
like falling off buildings
so what was like some of the stuff that
you did so for me i was doing fight
scenes right
right um so like i trained in uh you
know the hong kong style of action
and my master i shouldn't call my master
the guy who was training me
um he was on jackie chan's stunt team
throughout the
90s and 90s so he did movies like he did
a couple of the rush hours he did
shanghai noon
oh wow he did some of the smaller hong
kong ones like the twins effect
the movies right um but like
the way they work in hong kong is like i
should stop saying like so much that's
not good enough
you're less than us yeah they like oh my
god
the attitude okay the slogan of the
the slogan of the hong kong stuntman
association right he told me when he was
in it
risk life save money so that's the kind
of attitude
wow
a harder teacher in my life this dude
was so tough
right it's like you're expected to
backflip off a balcony whilst on fire
into a pool of broken glass
and if you're like a little bit hesitant
he's like no
no you're so weak what's wrong with you
that is hard enough that is the ultimate
charge
like a psychopath yeah but the
stunts kind of type a personality i
think
yeah yeah he was like he was telling me
stories about when
he was back in australia he was from
melbourne yeah we're in australia before
he went to hong kong was with jackie
right and just the stuff he did just as
a thing to do
was bonkers well like as a hobby hobby
but like he'd kind of do it towards
stunts
sort of but he was like one day we oh
we're driving past a train station in
melbourne
and you know there's like the bridge
that goes over the train yeah yeah
and then there's like a pole sticking up
like 10 meters away from it or something
yeah we've pulled
the dinghy doggy lights on it or
something yeah and he's like
yeah so yeah when i was younger before i
went to hong kong i was going to jump
off the bridge onto the pole
yeah i was going to do that if we didn't
have a camera at the time so
i'm like what yeah jump off
just for fun it's 10 meter jump from
this bridge on to catch a pole
just yeah to be like i did it just
because
here's a thing to do i think his
attitude was he would film it right
part of his stunt show reel right right
his attitude right
but that's the kind of people like just
fearless men so you're doing
there's a natural level of talent that's
required so the guys who become career
stunt men are generally speaking the
kids who were
you know the fastest runners in school
the kids who are naturally very
physically
right naturally very uh i'm not i was a
fat kid at school so i've got a level of
skills because i trained but i don't
have the natural talent for right right
yeah these guys man like i've got
friends who now are doing the stunts in
all the uh
like the marvel films and so forth okay
and they're just
just the moment they were born they were
better than me
after a hundred years of training you
know what i'm saying it's like my couple
of teachers this guy can just throw
himself off building so
god damn i wish that were me back
flipped out of the womb
with a six-pack
just ridiculous it's ridiculous oh my
goodness oh my god yeah so it's like
that's the level of natural talent
that's required but also when you get
that well a lot of them just
just crazy type a personality yeah
you have to be you can't you can't like
yeah if you're willing to be hit by a
car you know like just stand there we're
going to drive a car into you
okay
oh good take good dick all right again
yeah it's just all the ground legs it
was that good a lot of wrestlers as well
it's like you know okay so it's funny
we're pro wrestlers you're backstage in
the locker room yeah everyone's normally
so mellow
yeah i was just like oh i want to go
so chilled out and then okay so we'll go
into the ring and um yeah
about three minutes in or so you can um
hit me with the baseball bat
bob's wire i'm like he's like
they hit me with it here last week it's
still healing so you better hit me with
it here
[Laughter]
really are you sure that's what you want
me to do what do you want to do let's
take a quick break for this one-minute
break
it will be right back on the voice of
africa radio network